welcome to the David Pakman show i'm
Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire sitting
in for David Pakman today David is out
he is at a media and cryptocurrency
event but he will return tomorrow so
let's jump right in here one of the
biggest things happening right now in
this country is obviously gun control
because of the school shooting that took
place in Florida last week remarkably
the issue has not immediately died off
as is typically the case and it's still
staying fresh in Americans minds now the
students the survivors the family
members the classmates of those students
in South Florida have become incredibly
active in this fight for gun control in
the United States since the shooting
last week and yesterday I talked a bit
about how the Republicans the right-wing
media should say are starting to attack
these students well in the last 24 hours
the attacks on these survivors have
increased exponentially so here is what
we're hearing from right-wing media
today and we've been hearing this for
the last 24 hours or so as they develop
their narrative to attack these students
who were the survivors of this school
shooting first and foremost one of the
biggest conspiracy theories out there is
that these students are paid crisis
actors they're telling us that there's
footage of these students rehearsing
their lines before they go on TV you
know they seem a little too polished
when they give their delivery about the
issues they're a little too passionate a
little too well-spoken as if suddenly
having a 16 or 17 year old who can speak
well and get their point across is a bad
thing obviously this kid is an actor
according to some of these right-wing
conspiracy sites another one is that
they're not crisis actors but they are
being paid by the DNC and George Soros
the crisis actor thing implies that
these kids did not even go to this high
school the other theory is that they did
go to the high school they were there
but immediately after it happened
you had the DNC and George Soros drop in
start paying these students to become
politically active in the fight for gun
control there is zero evidence
whatsoever to back any of this up the
students themselves have been forced to
come out on social media and say yeah
we're not being paid by anyone we just
buried our classmates we're angry and we
want something done we want to feel safe
in our schools the other conspiracy
theory is that one of the students says
his father works for the FBI as a field
agent so he's become a vocal activist in
order to draw attention away from the
failures of the FBI in this particular
situation which yes
the FBI admitted that they've dropped
the ball on this but at the end of the
day it comes down to the weapon that the
kid used to go in there and shoot up the
school that's what this is about the
Republicans the right-wing media anyone
who tries to distract us from what is
actually happening have something to
gain from it specifically money from the
NRA they understand the power that these
young students in Florida and all over
this country have they understand that
these children high school students some
of them not even old enough to vote have
been so successful in the last few days
of organizing of getting out and
demanding change and it terrifies them
do you know why because these are the
next generation of American leaders
these are the people who twenty years
maybe even fifteen years from now are
gonna be running for Congress these are
the people who are gonna be writing our
laws who are gonna be running our states
running our government and Republicans
are terrified of that because these
students what they went through at that
school and what too many students across
this country have gone through if their
schools those images are burning their
brains they're never gonna forget that
they will take that image with them the
sounds the sights the horrors for the
rest of their lives it will impact
everything they do and so when we get a
generation of lawmakers that went
through these tragedies through these
massacre
we're gonna see some real change in this
country if we do not see it before then
which unfortunately at this point it's
not looking like we're gonna see too
much change in the very near future